spooky season is officially here and
there's nothing spookier than being
haunted by the September Games you
didn't finish yet here are 10 of the
biggest games releasing in October 2022.
after 2014's Advanced Warfare I
completely fell off of the Call of Duty
games that is until 2019's reboot of
Modern Warfare the game that got me into
the series in the first place sucked me
right back in since then I've been
waiting with baited breath for the
sequel and it's finally here Modern
Warfare 2 follows three years after the
events of Modern Warfare 2019 with
Captain Price and Task Force 141 now
fully formed and operating around the
world price is joined by the iconic
characters of Simon ghost Riley Kyle
gazgarek and John soap McTavish but this
newly assembled Task Force 141 also
includes a new character known as
Alejandro Vargas when it comes to the
game's multiplayer you can expect
typical Call of Duty modes like Team
Deathmatch domination and Search and
Destroy the popular large-scale ground
war mode from 2019's release is also
returning this year as part of a series
of modes on larger maps called battle
maps plus there will be two new round
base objective modes called prisoner
rescue and knockout Modern Warfare 2's
third confirmed mode is spec ops during
September's Call of Duty next event spec
ops was described as an in-depth
two-player Cooperative experience in
which players will venture to
large-scale hot zones with their
teammate to take part in branching
operations against redacted Modern
Warfare 2 is dropping on all consoles
except switch as well as PC where it
will return to steam for the first time
in years on October 28th war zone 2.0
and the DMZ mode will drop on November
16th
but for those of you that aren't into
military Sims and get more excited over
colorful hero Shooters and OverWatch 2
maybe more your speed if the two in the
title didn't already give it away
OverWatch 2 is the sequel to 2016's
OverWatch and will include some new
takes on the combat we saw in the
original game that includes a brand new
Mode called push in which two teams
fight to escort a robot into enemy
territory as well as the game switched
to 5v5 matches instead of the original
game's 6v6 model team composition is
also being adjusted so that teams only
contain one tank character so plan
accordingly when assembling your friends
to play along with those changes there
will be new content in the form of maps
and characters the maps include places
like Toronto Rio de Janeiro and Monte
Carlo while the characters include the
new faces of sojourn and junker Queen
just like the original OverWatch roster
these characters are sure to have some
fun Cosmetics however this time around
you won't be opening loot boxes to get
them instead there will be an in-game
store additional PVE content available
to purchase and battle passes that offer
in-game cosmetics and other fun perks
OverWatch 2's PVP mode will launch in
Early Access for free on every console
and PC October 4th the game's PVE mode
will be releasing sometime in 2023
while his predecessor saw Mario and
Company in familiar territory as the
Rabbids were transported to the Mushroom
Kingdom that won't be the case in Mario
plus Rabbids Sparks of Hope the
adventure will take our heroes across
multiple planets as they work together
to stop an evil influence Sparks of Hope
combines free roaming Exploration with
turn-based combat while wandering each
planet you're free to move as you wish
in order to solve puzzles and uncover
secrets and collectibles once you make
contact with an enemy however the game
switches to a turn-based strategy system
in a gameplay sneak peek trailer we saw
Bob's with glowing red eyes in what
appear to be possessed rabbits other
characters seem to have a less direct
link to the Mario universe so we could
see more original Creations this time
around one new feature coming to Sparks
of Hope are the titular Sparks they
resemble the stars from Super Mario
Galaxy but their faces have been
completely replaced by rabbits because
of course they have by collecting the
means that you can use their own special
abilities to enhance your combat skills
and there are dozens of different Sparks
to rescue barks of Hope is coming
exclusively to switch on October 20th
finally a gross looking game to fit
October's spooky Vibes ebb software's
scorn in gamespot's latest preview of
the game Jordan ramay wrote quote in
scorn you play as an unnamed person who
has become isolated in an unnerving
place where vicious looking living
tissue and twisted mechanical
Contraptions have been combined in an
uncanny relationship that seems
symbiotic in nature there are some
moments of first person shooting and
elements of horror in scorn but the game
is more focused on puzzle solving and
exploration not action or scares this
game seems to push its player towards
exploration and organic Discovery rather
than explain where to go and what to do
so if that's your favorite type of
experience you can uncover the mystery
when scoring Launches on Xbox series X
and S and PC on October 21st the game
will also launch day one on Xbox game
pass
Bruce Wayne is dead however not all hope
is lost and Gotham Knights you take
control of the bat family as they go
head to head with the seediest of the
city's underbelly in practice this means
players choose from one of four
characters Nightwing red hood Batgirl or
Robin you can play either alone or with
one friend in two-player Co-op because
despite four character options the story
is without a four player mode with a
similar free flow combat to the Arkham
games Gotham Knights looks a lot like
those beloved games but will seek to
give each hero their own flourishes you
can make Bruce Wayne proud on October
21st when Gotham Knight's releases on
PS5 series X and S and PC
and Bayonetta 3 the Umbra which teams up
with familiar faces as well as a new one
named Viola in order to put an end to
the terror of the mysterious evil known
as the homunculi these new baddies are
considered man-made bioweapons and
according to Viola hope for defeating
them lies with the scientists named
siegerd when it comes to the gameplay
fans of the Bayonetta series should be
very familiar with moves like witch time
and torture attack but part 3 will
introduce some new moves one of which is
called demon masquerade a move that
allows Bayonetta to unleash even more
magic power by fusing with an infernal
demon the other is called the demon
slave and this lets Bayonetta control
demons from a distance for some welcome
help in battle this feature is different
yet similar to the summoning of
Bayonetta 1 and 2. a major addition to
the Bayonetta series is what Platinum
games has named naive Angel mode and
according to the company it is a
revolutionary feature that will allow
more people to fully enjoy it while the
mode is off Bayonetta will be fully nude
with some sensitive areas covered up by
her magic hair whereas when the mode is
on she'll simply be wearing her full
outfit Bayonetta 3 is releasing
exclusively for switch on October 28th
a plague tail Requiem is an
action-adventure stealth game that takes
place shortly after the events of the
first game a plague tale innocence like
the original you play as amicia a young
girl tasked with escorting her younger
brother Hugo through a plague-stricken
world infested with rats and accompanied
by hostile soldiers along with amicia's
trusty slang Requiem introduces a
crossbow however like in innocence most
encounters will still call for a
stealthier approach you can throw
objects to attract the enemies attention
squeeze under tight spaces to hide from
View and track your enemies movements
with a vision Mode called rat sense new
to a plague tale Requiem is the ability
to directly control a horde of rats and
turn any enemy who dared to venture away
from an open flame into a snack become
king of the rats when Requiem releases
on PS5 Xbox series X and s switch and PC
on October 18th Dragon Ball the breakers
pits seven non powered human characters
AKA survivors against one player
controlled iconic villain from across
the Dragon Ball Universe the seven
humans must survive until the end of the
match using items and perks against the
villain who wins by eliminating all
other players the first three playable
villains include cell Boo and Frieza
whether you're playing as one of them or
as a Survivor you get to choose a
progression path unlock perks and
customize your character using skins the
breakers features a large map with
several areas of interest that can be
destroyed by the Raiders as they hunt
you down luckily the survivors have
weapons vehicles and grappling hooks to
increase their chance of escaping see
how long you can survive when Dragon
Ball the breakers releases on every
console and PC on October 14th
EA's professional ice hockey simulation
series returns to the ice this October
with NHL 23 and it promises some changes
and improvements over last year's game
one of the biggest updates for NHL 23
are Last Chance moves when players
stumble on the ice they can perform
desperation moves like shooting and
passing from their knees according to EA
more than 500 Last Chance moves have
been added to NHL 23. additionally AI
goalies are better and smarter and they
also have an increased library of
desperation save animations in total
there are around 350 new save animations
including more active and acrobatic
animations than past games and in at
first for the NHL series cross play
matchmaking is coming to NHL 23. the
feature won't be there in time for
launch but is expected to arrive in a
November update lace up your skates and
get back on the ice on October 14th when
NHL 2 23 drops on PC and every console
except switch
I guess you can say I've left the
spookiest for last because the final
game on our list is the winter expansion
for Resident Evil Village this DLC
features an all-new story called Shadows
of rose that takes place after the main
village campaign you take control of
Rose Winters as she seeks to rid herself
of powers unlike the main game shadow of
Rose is exclusively in the third person
perspective putting it more in line with
the remakes of Resident Evil 2 and 3.
this DLC is coming to PC stadia and
every console except switch on October
28th switch owners will have the
pleasure of playing a cloud version of
the main village campaign on that same
day and if that wasn't enough Resident
Evil releases for the 28th reverse is
coming to PS4 Xbox One and PC on that
same day
so which of these games are you most
interested in and are there any that you
can't wait to play that didn't make the
list let us know in the comments you can
follow me on Twitter at Devonte Chisholm
and make sure you're subscribed to
Gamespot for more
[Music]